voilà Emmanuel et Brigitte Macron a cru
accueilli par Joe et Gilles Biden la
France et les États-Unis font face à
l'ambition de conquête de Vladimir
Poutine et à la guerre brutale de la
Russie contre l'Ukraine qui a eu une
nouvelle fois fracassée la paix sur le
continent européen à son retour de la
guerre sur le sol européen suite à
l'agression russe contre l'Ukraine et
face aux crises multiples qui frappent
nos nations et nos sociétés
il nous faut savoir
redevenir frère d'armes quelques heures
plus tôt pourtant le discours est moins
amical devant la Communauté française à
Washington revenant sur l'inflation
réduction actes programme
d'investissement et de subventions de
430 milliards de dollars
et l'Europe que pour toutes celles et
ceux qui travaillent dans nombre
d'entreprises ils vont juste se dire on
fait plus d'investissement de l'autre
côté de l'océan lors d'un dîner avec des
élus américains il est même allé
beaucoup plus loin ces propos ont été
transmis par un participant à l'AFP
mettez-vous à ma place je ne veux pas
devenir un marché pour les produits
américains parce que j'ai exactement les
mêmes produits que vous vous allez
peut-être régler votre problème mais
vous allez aggraver le mien je suis
navré d'être aussi direct c'est ici dans
cette salle de contrôle à l'adresse
tenue secrète que des opérateurs
couperont l'électricité si besoin cet
hiver les fameux délestage bonjour
Sébastien Sarrazin alors qui va vous
donner l'ordre de couper l'électricité
certes qui nous l'enverra on n'est pas
en train de dire aux Français qu'on aura
des coupures cet hiver on est en train
de dire aux Français que s'il fait je
sais pas 5 6 7 degrés de moins au mois
de janvier que les mois de janvier
habituels et que donc on est obligé de
puiser beaucoup dans les réserves
d'électricité pour se chauffer s'il y
avait des tensions sur la ligne on ne
laissera pas des situations à arrivé et
donc on est dans l'anticipation pour le
1er janvier on aura 75 gigawatts qui
sont sûrs et un hiver normal ils nous en
faut souvent 80 85 90 95 GB donc on voit
qu'a probabilité qu'on soit échec à un
moment donné et quand même relativement
élevé et là c'est plus un délestage
c'est un blackout c'est déjà arrivé
plusieurs fois en Europe vous avez des
réactions en chaîne et vous pouvez
éteindre très rapidement un pays de pays
trois pays ça ça me fait beaucoup plus
peur que finalement ce délestage quelle
Houellebecq leur déchange avec Michel
Onfray
qui a déclaré au sujet du Grand
remplacement écoutez et lisez
qu'on appelle ça une théorie
ce n'est pas une théorie c'est un fait
quels sont les pays qui délaissent au
niveau d'électricité bah en fait ce sont
les pays du tiers-monde ce sont l'Inde
le Pakistan le Bangladesh le Sri Lanka
et de se dire effectivement que la
France est tombée au niveau de ces
pays-là c'est un petit peu inquiétant il
est sur une ligne aujourd'hui qui est en
courant français intellectuel que je
vais qualifier d'extrême droite et
mauriens qui pensent que notre pays est
en train d'être remplacé par une autre
civilisation ça ne signifie rien mais
que si tu oublies je ne suis pas
d'accord avec lui mais dans le quotidien
des gens c'est pas une période très gaie
et très rose c'est une évidence et le
nier ce serait se voiler la face et ce
que nous disons aux Français c'est qu'à
chaque fois qu'on a fait face à des
crises on a été parmi les peuples les
plus solidaires et les plus costauds du
monde et ça il n'y a pas de raison que
ça change lors d'un forum à Bruxelles
consacré aux investissements pour la
ville de Kiev la maire de Paris Anne
Hidalgo s'est permis de donner un
conseil à Vladimir kritchco le frère du
maire de la capitale ukrainienne pour
reconstruire sa ville vous devez avoir
un plan si vous souhaitez reconstruire
pour transformer les infrastructures
urbaines
et passer de la voiture au vélo
c'est très intéressants
il y a il y a exactement l'esprit du
savoir-faire français faire la promotion
du vélo à un pays en guerre une honte
pour de nombreux internautes français
d'autres enrouleront préférés s'amuser
avec notamment des arrêts sur image de
clitschko au rayon gênant difficile de
faire mieux